Привет! Это третий урок модуля System Architect. В прошлом уроке мы подключили Figma MCP. У агента теперь есть руки, которыми он может записывать что-то в Figma. Сегодня первая боевая задача модуля — берём PRD и получаем сайт-мэп и юзерфлоу сразу на FigJam Canvas. У нас уже есть PRD в нашей среде разработки, есть директива, которая будет в описании к этому уроку, как это обычно бывает, и, в общем-то,
ничего нам не мешает её запустить прямо сейчас и посмотреть, как это работает. Я буду продолжать со своим кейсом из прошлого модуля.
Давайте немного поговорим о том, как эта директива работает, на что она подразделена. Там вообще два этапа. Директива устроена так: сначала всё делается в текстовых файлах, как это обычно у нас бывает, мы собираем инвентаризацию экранов, то есть какие вообще экраны должны быть, сайт-мап дерева, приоритеты, что для нас важнее всего, и юзерфлоу в Mermaid.
Это формат диаграмм. Мы сейчас посмотрим ещё, как с ним работать. После этого шага, после того, как она создала вот эти все, всю текстовую фазу, да, она у нас запрашивает ревью.
Мы смотрим, проверяем, что он сделал, правим, если что-то не нравится, общаемся с агентом, не стесняемся это делать. И только после того, как всю эту структуру, именно в текстовом виде, мы готовы опрувнуть, мы сообщаем об этом агенту, и он переходит ко второму этапу.
Уже создаёт диаграммы. Диаграммы, сайт-мапы, юзерфлоу мы будем делать в FigJam. Давайте для тех, кто не знает, что это такое, покажу, как это выглядит и где оно находится.
Мы заходим в FigJam, как обычно, есть у нас FigJam. Можем создать новый документ, как это мы делаем с обычными файлами FigJam, но здесь всё ориентировано именно на создание блок-схем, на командный брейншторм и так далее.
То есть здесь мы можем создавать блоки, создавать следующее, описывать тем самым флоу, делать такие ветвления и так далее.
То есть это инструмент именно для диаграмм внутри фигмы.
Помимо него ещё используют мира, инструмент тоже достаточно распространён, но крайне неудобно перемещать контент из мира в фигму, из фигмы обратно в мира.
На бесплатном тарифе там условия так себе, каждое действие практически платное, поэтому я крайне рекомендую использовать для этого всего FigJam.
Почему мы так дробим задачу? Потому что у нас токены не бесконечные, контекст не бесконечный и лучше поэтапно сначала разобраться с текстом, со всей структурой и только потом через MCP заставлять его что-то собирать.
Потому что, напомню, если забыли, все действия с MCP едят очень много токенов.
Ну и помимо токенов ещё ждать приходится, кому это нужно.
Итак, директиву я у себя уже прогнал, запустил, как обычно мы это делаем. Давай посмотрим, какие она собрала нам файлы.
Первое, что она собрала из нашего PRD это Screens Inventory, то есть все скрины, все экраны, которые у нас должны быть, все которые описаны в PRD, их название и краткое описание этих экранов.
У меня всё собрано на английском. Если ты хочешь, чтобы был на русском языке для удобства, то можно попросить его это сделать, с этим проблем никаких нет.
Но в дальнейшем, всё равно, когда мы будем заставлять уже собирать эти экраны, то он всё равно будет делать это на английском.
То есть, именно фреймы называть. И здесь, конечно, лучше, чтобы и тут было на английском, и там, чтобы за эту взаимосвязь он в дальнейшем ловил.
Поэтому я советую оставить на английском, но прямо если сильно глаз режет, можешь поменять на русский.
Здесь, в принципе, углубляться смысла нет. Мы видим, описаны просто все экраны. Как обычно, это MD-файлик. Можно в превью его открыть, посмотреть.
Давай перейдём к следующему файлу. Далее у нас sitemap. Дерево глубиной в три слоя.
Этого достаточно для того, чтобы начинать точно.
Если ты хочешь увеличить глубину, чтобы было ещё больше уровня, ещё глубже проработка,
здесь, в директиве, ты можешь заранее указать, что глубина не максимум 3 уровня, а, там, не знаю, например, 10.
И он максимально глубоко тебе всё это дело распишет.
Но, конечно, потратить время, токены, и если ты на PRO-подписки, то тебе может их не хватить на формирование всего этого дерева.
Далее у нас идут файлы поинтереснее. Это signup to first server flow и low balance recovery.
Далее у нас идут файлы поинтереснее. Это уже диаграммы, описанные вот в текстовом формате.
Посмотреть их можно прямо здесь, внутри, через расширение.
Давай покажу, как оно называется.
Заходим здесь в расширение и находим Mermaid Viewer.
Также пишем сюда Mermaid и находим вот это расширение, в котором плавник какой-то кита.
Оно работает быстрее и лучше всех из тех, что я пробовал.
Когда мы это расширение установили, можем выбрать любой из файликов.
Здесь у нас загорится, что у нас формат этот воспринят уже нашим расширением.
Тут у нас сменится иконка, что скажет о том, что наше расширение воспринимает этот файл как то, с чем можно работать.
Если же этого у тебя не произошло, просто перезапусти свою среду разработки, в данном случае Antigravity, и все это дело появится.
Теперь, когда мы открываем наши файлы такого формата, Mermaid, у нас появляется здесь кнопочка Preview Diagram.
Можно на нее нажать и посмотреть, как эта диаграмма будет выглядеть.
То есть, как она выглядит структурно, оценить, насколько здесь правдоподобная логика.
То же самое можем сделать со вторым файликом.
Вот здесь у меня уже другой Flow.
Все, с этим можно работать, это уже нормальная визуализация.
Вот можем выбрать какой-нибудь другой, другие цвета, другую тему, чтобы удобнее с этим всем работать.
Это позволяет оценить, насколько вообще правдоподобно он это дерево собрал, потому что в таком текстовом формате работать с этим, конечно, неудобно.
Общаемся с чатиком, правим, дорабатываем.
Если нас все устраивает, то мы переходим к следующему этапу.
Здесь, смотрите, очень важный момент.
На втором этапе он предлагает вам два пути отрисовки этого дизайна.
Через Generate Diagram и через Use Figma.
Это два разных метода, которые открывает нам Figma MCP.
Мы уже видели, что через Drop мы можем вызывать команды.
Вместе с этими MCP вот это большое количество команд подключается к агенту.
И нам вовсе не обязательно знать каждую из них, вызывать их вручную.
Но конкретно здесь есть принципиальная разница.
Generate Diagram это команда, которая прямо вот рассчитана именно под FIGGEM.
То есть работу с диаграммами и прочим.
И она намного быстрее выполняет эти функции.
Очень быстро собирает там эти диаграммы.
Но у нее есть ограничения.
Ты вызываешь эту команду и она выполняется каждый раз в новом файлике.
То есть ты не можешь сказать вот в этом FIGGEM файле поправь мне вот эту диаграмму.
Или добавь сюда еще одну диаграмму.
Ты не можешь выбрать какой-то FIGGEM файлик уже готовый.
И попросить его вот сюда добавь мне диаграмму.
Или обнови ту, которая уже есть.
Нет.
Generate Diagram только генерирует новый файлик диаграммы с нуля.
Который этот метод править не может.
То есть ты вручную можешь что-то править.
Но это нужно учитывать.
То есть он делает быстрее.
Он больше под FIGGEM адаптирован.
Но он каждый раз создает новый файл.
UseFigma мы уже затрагивали, что он позволяет вообще рисовать, взаимодействовать с любыми макетами в обычном дизайне FIGGEM.
В обычном режиме.
Но также и в FIGGEM в этом формате он тоже прекрасно со всеми файлами взаимодействует.
Может менять их цвета, положение, действительно отрисовывать диаграммы.
Но он делает это дольше.
Он тратит больше токенов.
И не всегда у него идеально получается диаграмму визуализировать.
Он под это меньше адаптирован.
Соответственно, при первой итерации, когда мы в первый раз создаем эту диаграмму,
мы просим это делать именно через Generate диаграмму.
Если мы что-то в ней дорабатываем,
или для нас принципиально важно, чтобы она визуально красивее получилась,
то используем UseFigma.
Но имей в виду, что у тебя потратится больше токенов,
это займет больше времени.
И насколько это целесообразно, не знаю, сомнительно.
Давай посмотрим, как результат будет отличаться от конкретно на моем проекте.
Итак, вот наш FigJam файл.
Когда он создает его, он сразу дает тебе ссылку,
и ты ее открываешь в браузере.
Что у нас здесь?
Вот у меня мой сайтмэп, и он его полностью отрисовал.
Как мы и просили его в директиве, у нас тут только три уровня,
и сами блоки тоже по цветам разбиты.
Те блоки, что у нас желтые, они имеют меньшую приоритетность,
но тут, как видишь, у меня впереди устроен таким образом,
что все эти блоки важны,
потому что здесь у нас еще только три уровня,
то есть, скорее всего, какие-то более специфичные штуки
будут на более глубоких уровнях,
и именно там появится больше этих желтых блоков.
Но, тем не менее, здесь у меня он только один,
но имею в виду, что в директиве описано,
что при создании диаграммы, при создании сайтмэпа,
нужно отмечать, что у нас приоритетнее именно цветами.
В общем, здесь все страницы есть,
Home, Legal, Lending и так далее.
Все то, что у меня в PRD и в моей структуре было описано.
Это было собрано именно через Generate Diagram.
Также, если мы сейчас перейдем на другую страницу,
это уже User Flow.
Вот, он собрал мне первый Flow,
а затем на другой странице, на еще одной,
собрал второй,
после чего я просто его скопировал
и перенес на страницу первого.
Вот, по визуалу,
ну, как видим, здесь все логично,
все аккуратно,
все собрано вот в формате такой блок схемы,
ну, в общем, не буду объяснять,
что такое блок схемы,
я думаю, и так все прекрасно знают.
Это можно дальше редактировать,
дополнять, расширять и так далее.
Здесь Flow достаточно простой,
потому что особо я этот проект не углублял,
но, тем не менее,
все у нас здесь есть.
Здесь уже схема посложнее,
схема с отправкой постоянных писем
о том, что баланс заканчивается на аккаунте.
Здесь у нас есть такое ветвление
и на самом деле,
во-первых, выглядит достаточно просто,
а во-вторых,
самый ли это оптимальный путь вот это изобразить?
Вроде как понятно, неплохо выглядит,
но это опять было создано через Generate Diagram,
а что если с самого начала использовать UseFigma?
Вот пример вот этого Flow,
как раз таки он,
ну, тут достаточно сложно,
так изображен,
хотя, по сути, штука простая.
У нас первое сообщение,
второе, третье,
если на каждое из них он не отвечает,
ну, ему приходит следующее.
Если отвечает,
то мы переводим его на экран.
То есть, идея простая,
но визуализация достаточно сложная.
И здесь UseFigma справился лучше.
Тут схема намного чище, проще и понятнее.
Но здесь он, например, не учел,
что при создании диаграмм,
там обязательно нужно указывать
в ветвлениях название с выбором клиента,
да, почему переход совершается.
Он этого не учел,
потому что под диаграммой он не так хорошо адаптирован,
но тем не менее Flow он этот отрисовал
аккуратнее и как-то прозрачнее.
Вот, если подводить итоги,
визуально UseFigma делает покруче,
но дольше и жрет больше токенов.
Именно в плане создания диаграмм,
GenerateDiagram, конечно, работает лучше, быстрее
и больше под это адаптирован.
Также давайте отдельно отметим,
где стоит приглядывать в этом процессе за агентом.
Во-первых, это выдуманные экраны.
Он может дорисовать того,
чего у нас нет в PRD.
В директиве установлено,
чтобы он этого не делал,
но, тем не менее, такие артефакты бывают, всплывают.
И тут нужно самому обращать внимание на то,
что он добавляет.
Но такое возникает на самом деле не часто.
Также глубокое дерево,
он может отрисовать больше уровней.
Следим за уровнями вложенности,
потому что, во-первых,
для первой итерации нам точно много их не нужно.
Во-вторых, каждый новый уровень,
это еще большая детализация,
то есть еще больше этих блоков,
еще больше будет затрачено времени и токенов
на отрисовку всего этого дерева.
Поэтому три уровня нам вполне достаточно.
И третья проблема заключается в том,
что если у нас большой объем,
например, того же сайтмэп,
то у нас качество немного теряется.
Для того, чтобы это произошло,
он должен быть действительно очень большим.
Но в таких случаях можно дробить
и итеративно собрать разные куски,
а потом объединить в одну большую диаграмму.
Итак, теперь давайте перейдем к гатамашке.
Не хочется вам давать какие-то бесполезные мини-кейсы,
которые будут у всех одинаковые.
Хочется все-таки, чтобы вы продолжали работать на тем,
с чем уже начали.
Но в то же время,
работа через MCP тратит много токенов,
тратит много времени.
И задача именно по прохождению модуля
просто ознакомиться с этим workflow
и понять, как это вообще работает,
что с этим всем делать
и чего вообще ожидать от этого подхода.
Мы берем PRD из своего прошлого проекта,
который был у нас на предыдущем модуле.
Также проходим текстовые фазы,
то есть инвентаризация, сайтмап,
приоритеты, юзерфлоу.
В тексте все это оформляем,
следим, чтобы он...
То есть собираем эту текстовую базу,
то есть по сути первую фазу просто директивы проходим,
следим, чтобы он там все нормально изложил,
чтобы не было никаких артефактов,
то есть не просто бежим по следующим этапам,
а ознакомливаемся с тем,
что он нам делает.
И в конце FIGGEM создать нужно будет канвас
через первый метод Generate Diagram.
Это либо сайтмап,
либо один юзерфлоу на ваш выбор.
Если у вас проект не очень большой,
вы видите там по экранам,
что не такая уж у вас большая история,
то вполне можно выполнить и то, и другое.
Если видите, что много экранов,
сложная структура,
можете ограничиться чем-то одним,
просто чтобы сэкономить токены.
В качестве домашнего задания
нужно будет прислать ссылку на FIGGEM,
где у вас эта диаграмма выполнена.
На этом все.
Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания
и увидимся в следующем уроке.